huh what change his face oh Jesus yeah
so I heard he's retired right Connor
yeah you don't buy it right I don't know
yeah if you had to guess yeah
he's fighting yet Hans mollenkamp you
know Hans mmm-hmm from Monster yes yeah
a picture sparring with Connor today
oh so Congress training yeah I know
how's he doing something whose monsters
yeah yeah yeah it works for monster he's
he's training he's gonna fight he's
probably just fucking with people you
know I mean Connors a master showman in
terms of like how to keep people
interested in him and I just think he
just he got way out of line with all
this khabib stuff but I'd like the way
I'd like the way he takes his losses oh
he took it well I like me I like the way
he goes out there and talk smack with
every win I think like as a I mean I
like from a sports psychology point of
view I think he's uh
you think he's developed there you know
yeah but I don't think the way to get
another fight with khabib is to continue
to talk shit after he smashes you I mean
he doesn't have any reason to you can
just talk shit like he he didn't just
win he smashed and tapped you like it
was there's only like one or two moments
in the fight where Connor was taking
control with some of the striking in the
stand-up mhm
you know and that's another choke that's
another misunderstood choke that fulcrum
choke there him beep Connor with that is
it legit yeah net crank yeah yeah and
people that don't think to all he tap to
that like you attended to and if you
didn't you're stupid and people like it
because the chin was down there right
there like you there's a lot when you're
there's a lot of it generates a lot of
force yeah take it down hinge your jaw
from oh yeah yeah
face apart yeah yeah yeah that that's a
legit that's a legit submission yeah
especially with that yeah yeah exactly
yeah back the the back of your forum
against the guys back as leveraged you
know which causes that fulcrum yeah
that's horrific it's a very powerful
yeah it hurts bad man there's a lot of
those neck crank so just like oh you
watch people and you just go please tap
yeah there it is right there like you
see yeah
with khabib 's arm the way you're
pressing against the back of connor and
then also yank on that and that is
ripping his
fucking neck apartment yeah you never
yeah you you until you felt one yeah
yeah um but Connor it's interesting that
the way he's posted up like that he's
trying to get up and he's getting
cracked at the same time
yeah he got it kind of he was already
hit have been smashed by then too you
know he'd been hit and hit with so many
big punches from the top he takes a
great shot that I'll tell you that yeah
but it's just one of those things where
I think in order for him to really have
a real chance at getting another shot
what he's got to do is beat somebody big
and say something that makes khabib
considerate you know but not a no not in
the way of what he's been doing in terms
of you know talking shit about him and
talking smack I mean I think the only
way it's gonna be public demand like
he's gonna have to get to a position
where people want to see him fight for I
began to see that the result may be
different this time
mm-hmm and then maybe if he could just
fucking communicate something to him say
you know I respect you you know all
trash talk aside you know I would like
to test myself against you one more time
and I think I earned it I think that's
the only way he's gonna get it I think
the only way he's gonna get it is to to
win a couple of fights beat some real
big name guys and then make it so it's a
something that could be he's actually
interested in well okay so I don't know
if that's the only way but it's the way
that would be that I would like to see
they already offered it to be even
khabib said fuck off yeah yeah but like
that path that you're talking about
sounds like a one that one that fits
good for me yeah I'd like to see it that
that way yeah do you think that
trash-talking in MMA has gone too far
got it all right I mean well I think
it's entertaining yeah for some people I
think it's not well here it's it's hard
well kids it's not it's not always what
I want to see and it's not I know it's
not the type of person I am but not
everyone's gonna be me that's not what
makes the world go around right as a lot
of people want to see it and also
sometimes it does bring some energy and
some you know when it's well done it
does bring some energy and some excited
fight and to the sport and at the same
time not every fight what Sinjin what I
think what's really interesting and
what's really excited about the UFC is
that there's a lot of fights that people
want to see that have no bearing on the
title right and so there's something to
that
fights that just people want to see and
I think trash talk sometimes makes
weight that people want to see yeah for
sure
yeah it makes me emotional makes things
intense it's great for selling things
it's great for selling paper views but
the question is like is it good for the
sport overall and should it be something
that we encourage well hi well that's
for and that's the thing is how do we
decide what's good for the sport in what
way right how do we decide is it good
for the way the sport do you want the
sport to look as far as martial arts and
being a respectful thing and people
looking at us like that maybe not is it
good for the supporters of the growth of
the sport and for more opportunities for
our athletes and for our athletes to
become names that uh that draw attention
from other people that normally didn't
know about it I don't know I don't know
either yeah so so I don't know I I'm
torn mm-hmm I like both yeah I got a
Machida type character that's very spec
foam the house and never talks trash and
fights like you know just a world
champion caliber martial artist and I
also like God talks mad shit you think
it's funny yeah yeah exactly I enjoy it
oh oh it's like I like press conferences
for that very reason
we're you know guys are talking shit to
each other and they're just looking over
at each other on the podium and you know
it's funny oh come on if some of them
yeah some of it is hilarious yeah how
about Connor when Jeremy Stephenson
asked him for fighter who the fuck is
that guy no it was effective we got a
when he got off with his like okay I
don't have time to insult everyone so
let's yeah let's get them all in one
place right that was great I could
thought everyone at one time let's be
efficient gentlemen this comedy back
when he was talking about where it's red
panties night yeah yeah that was we made
it baby we got that kind of a girl fight
he's a fucking character man come on
he's in that weird situation though
where he really never has to fight again
so you got to wonder what his motor
vation is you know like he has a hundred
million dollars he has a gigantic
whiskey company that proper 12 is
murdering it that that place is killing
it that that company is there they're
moving into other countries now I mean
they're killing it he doesn't have to do
a thing ever
financially right unless you want to eat
diamond sandwiches he's like basically
do whatever the fuck he wants for the
rest of his life and just live off
interest but he still likes to fight
yeah I think so yeah I mean that's what
brought him into the key be fight you
didn't have to fight could be even but
just you know how much does he want it I
mean does he want it the same way a guy
like style bender wants it or guy like
Kelvin Kelvin Gastelum wants it and also
I think that you know part of one unit
is different to maybe maybe there's
maybe people might want things on their
terms to answer in terms of way you get
it is way like it's like some people
like all you'll want it I'm wondering
any way I can get it some people might
want it and say well now I want it this
way well he was gonna fight cowboy that
was a fight that they were they were
basically trying to make but it was
gonna have to be a co main event and
because of that I think Conner was not
interested in anymore he wanted to be a
main event you know I'm like Jesus like
is that really what kept us from Connor
vs. cowboy guys right right yeah under
vs. cowboy make that a fuckin main event
like make some malarkey title come up
with some 160 pound title or some shit
just come on man do it I mean they give
out these interim titles left and right
how about you come up with more excited
when that was gonna help yeah yeah I was
excited to see it 165-pound malarkey
title just come on man you Connor versus
cowboy for the title yeah make a title
up but that was make it yeah I agree I
don't think it would hurt at all but
apparently dana says it makes a big
difference in the amount of pay per
views okay yeah